before Donald Trump became president he
was better known for this you're fired
you're fired you're fired Donald Trump
was known through and through as a New
Yorker a businessman a socialite
essentially that reputation is now at
the center of Trump's civil fraud trial
in Manhattan where he and his adult
children face allegations that they
falsify the value of their assets for
millions in ill-gotten gains this is a a
rare scenario where you have a case of
this financial significance
with a player of this public visibility
and involving so much real estate so
many Assets in New York here's how
Trump's civil fraud trial could deal a
blow to the former president's New York
Empire and the business Titan Persona
he's built over the course of
decades Trump faces four criminal
indictments related to his time as
president but for him the Civil fraud
case in Manhattan court is personal this
could have potentially crippling effects
on Donald Trump's business interest in
New York and the Trump organization's
ability to continue to do business in
New York he spent decades pursuing
business deals across the city
residential
commercial in a 2022 lawsuit New York
attorney general Laticia James accused
Trump and his adult children of engaging
in a decade long scheme to fraudulently
and falsely value their assets resulting
in $250 million in unlawful gains James
a Democrat and a vocal critic of trump
alleges the former president was able to
obtain bank loans on more favorable
terms by overvaluing his real
estate these properties include Trump's
Flagship Manhattan building Trump Tower
an office building known as 40 Wall
Street the Residential Building Trump
Park Avenue and in a state north of New
York City known as Seven Springs cases
like this are not rare but uh this is
one of the most unusual ones because of
the high-profile identity of the person
involved the fact that it involves
substantial number of properties with
high values uh in New York the lawsuit
said the triplex apartment in Trump
Tower was calculated at 30,000 ft when
in reality it's nearly 11,000 ft that
resulted in a valuation of $327 million
in 2015 more than triple the record
setting price for any apartment ever
sold in the city at that point and at
Trump Park Avenue the lawsuit claimed 12
rent stabilized units were appraised at
$750,000 total according to Trump's
financial statements in 2011 and 2012
those units were valued as if they were
unrestricted for nearly $50
million in the law there is no bright
line uh between what constitutes a
reasonable perhaps exaggeration but when
you get to the point where the uh
statement of value is so many multiples
10 20 100 times what would be shown to
to be the actual value a judge or jury
can draw the conclusion if he wishes and
it would be justified that this is a um
a
fraud Trump has denied any wrongdoing
and called the case a Witch Hunt his
lawyers have argued that his business
dealings have been profitable for the
banks involved the banks got back their
money again there was never a default
there was never a problem everything was
perfect there was no crime in the early
proceedings before the trial a New York
judge ruled that Trump and two of his
adult children Eric Trump and Donald
Trump Jr committed fraud both Donald
Trump Jr and Eric Trump have criticized
the ruling saying they relied on the
company's accountants to compile their
father's financial statements Ivanka
Trump was dismissed from the case after
an appeals court rule the state's legal
claims against her were too old in
September the judge ordered the
cancellation of business certificates
that allowed Trump to operate in the
state which could lead him to lose
control of some New York properties
you can't just take assets from somebody
without compensation if this goes
forward there has to be a process which
is certainly fair to the defendant to
Trump to realize the pro proper value of
those assets whether or not that Trump
name was going to come off the buildings
is very much intertwined with what is
the way to realize the most value if
those assets are
sold going there Trump is not hiding at
all his displeasure with his entire
process this is a case that should have
never been brought it's a case that
should be dismissed immediately the
fraud was on behalf of the Court the
Attorney General wants to prohibit Trump
and his company from entering into New
York State Commercial Real Estate
Acquisitions and applying for loans with
state registered lenders for 5 years in
early January James said Trump and his
company should pay about $370 million in
penalties more than the $250 million she
originally estimated for their ill
gotten gains there's a lot of questions
of where Trump would get the cash freed
up to satisfy that one possibility is he
would have to sell some some properties
off or or other assets to free up that
amount of cash in October an appeals
court temporarily postponed the
cancellation of Trump's business
certificates while his lawyers contested
the ruling the irony here is if this
goes forward and Trump is no longer
involved the very thing that he says uh
would lend extraordinary value to these
properties beyond for example the
appraisal values would haunt him because
these properties would no longer have
the Trump brand and the values that
would be realized one would think would
be substantially lower some legal
experts say Trump's lawyers seem focused
on building a detailed legal record for
an appeal the appet road is long and it
is not quick and if we consider where we
are now I think that the scale tips
heavily in favor of the Trump
organization in being able to delay any
final resolution of this case until
after the next presidential election
politically Trump has so far you know
use this and and the other legal
travails that he faces to paint himself
as a victim of political persecution in
a lot of ways it's worked with
Republican core voters but a loss could
kind of turn the tables on that some of
his legal problems could compound and
and you know he could be hurt in the
face of Voters as he tries to return to
the White House